okay let's go you know every time I do
this I'm stepping into the lion's den
but let's go to the to10 area code we
have a lot of trolls from San Antonio
and any time I pick up on two-one-zero
it's a risk but I'm doing it caller from
to10
who's this where you're calling from my
name is Andre and yes I'm calling from
San Antonio hey what's going on Andre I
have I guess two topic that I'd like to
address you and I and by the way I love
you so thank you I'm more right-leaning
but I do appreciate the thought that you
put in to your work sure thank you
the two topics I guess you can choose
which one you'd want to talk about are
between integration and I get in health
care I've done quite a bit of research
on both ends and well why don't you pick
one and just tell me you know what your
question is about it okay let's go let's
go with health care then because my
question for you in healthcare is if you
know anything about how health care was
wrong in the 20s and you know early 1900
yeah well so there it depends on what
industry so we actually just did a piece
about how when the sailing industry was
really big bigger in the United States
the founders now this is prior to 1900
obviously put in place a mandatory tax
that was paid for both by the ship
owners and the sailors which was used to
pay for their health care which was sort
of a government mandate for health
coverage and then in the period between
skipping ahead World War one in World
War two the US was going in the
direction of more of a European type
system and wendell potter outlines this
in his book deadly spin and because at a
time when we weren't getting along with
germany it sounded a little too much
like what the germans are doing it was
abandoned and we ended up with the
system that that we have now which is
unfortunate you know i perspective ya
know yeah we ended up with the worst of
both worlds yet honest
there was a small period of time where
there is a good amount of physician
groups where you could pretty much
localize your health care
and have you know you know series of
different you know specialties of
doctors that you could you could pay for
health insurance through them and you
don't pay the doctors for health
insurance or you pay them for health
care I'm not fully understanding it's
for health care it's it's you know
directly directly from the doctors
there's not an intermediary got it like
there is today okay
essentially one of the one of the issues
that I see with today's health insurance
is that the doctors are completely
unable to price their own they're their
own service essentially the insurance
companies tell them how much they're
gonna get paid is that correct yeah I
mean it's not untrue it's it's true that
they are if you're mostly I mean a
doctor could say we are not going to
accept insurance and then they can
charge whatever they want and in fact
doctors have doctors do come up with
their own book rate like for example I
know a lot of people who work in mental
health and they will say our rate is a
hundred and eighty dollars for an hour
psychotherapy session but for people who
have say Tufts health insurance we've
agreed to accept 98 dollars for the hour
so it's sort of their call as to whether
they want to say we're not accepting
that's 100% accurate to the way health
insurance is done for the majority of
doctors essentially what doctors have to
do is is price their their services
higher than what they would ever you
know reasonably charge as a single
person because no matter what the
insurance companies are going to have
reimbursement rates based on their
records right well they're different
this is getting into some complicated
there's two different things going on
part of the wreath at the insurance
companies negotiate a lower rate and in
a sense yes if a doctor says in my
example if they say well I charge six
hundred dollars an hour for
psychotherapy or they charge two hundred
like either way the insurance company
has an amount that they've determined
for psychiatrists psychologists and
social workers
and licensed Marriage and Family
Therapist that they reimburse so part of
what you're pointing to is that in order
to account for non-payment and stuff
that gets written off that's another
element that pushes these sort of list
prices above what any insurance company
actually pays this is there's many
factors here now my problem my problem
with the insurance industry as it is
today is exactly that I feel like the
doctors don't have autonomy in their own
practices to to cater their health care
locally which is how health care is
administered to their to their patients
so how would you give my so my largest
my so let me finish real quick my
largest issue with with possibly going
to an even bigger and more controlling
single-payer healthcare system would be
just the enlargement of that whole issue
where doctors are going to be targeting
the ridiculous of how insurance
companies are gonna be negotiating
different then all the negotiation is
going to be done on the government side
with the FDA and other things and we're
just completely out of control out of
control yeah but I think I understand
what you're saying conceptually but if
you actually go to a real single-payer
system that that has significantly less
importance and we've sort of outlined
why in our in our segments about it
listen I got a run it's very interesting
what you're bringing up I think you're
just off a little bit in terms of some
of the context but this is complicated
stuff and I'm very glad that you're
thinking about it let's go to a break
that is it for today we will take calls
again very very soon